(applause)
- [Gary] Thank you.
Thank you guys for having me.
I'm super excited
to be here actually.
Let me some context on where I
come from because I'm going to
assume that a lot of you
don't know and then I'll spiel a
little bit about a couple point
of view I have that might be
interesting given the audience.
And then I'd love to go into Q&amp;A
'cause I think that's when the
most interesting stuff happens.
So I was born in the
former Soviet Union.
I came to the US
when I was three.
We grew up super poor.
I lived in a studio apartment
in Queens with eight
family members.
It was a really
tough upbringing.
My dad got a job as a stock
boy in a liquor store making
two bucks an hour.
I kinda grew up with that
American dream
merchant kind of world.
We were very immigrant saved
every dollar and eventually five
or six years into the US my dad
bought a small liquor store
in New Jersey.
I moved to Jersey
when I was six.
I was very entrepreneurial
lemonade stand, baseball cards,
washing cars, raking leaves,
shoveling snow anything to kinda
make a buck.
When I was in the US, when I was
12 or 13 baseball cards were a
very big deal.
Everybody collected them.
I was making one to $2000 a
weekend selling baseball cards
as a 12, 13-year-old.
Probably the
richest I'll ever be.
That was great but then I turned
14 and I was first-generation
oldest son from the old country
which meant I got put dragged
into my dad's liquor store.
Got paid two bucks an hour to
bag ice for 15 hours a day.
So it's kind of hard core.
I always tell a lot of my
friends that I grew up much more
like their grandparents than
they did 'cause we were
so first-generation.
When I was 17 I realized that
people collected wine and that
was a big deal for me because I
didn't want to go into my family
business though I wanted to
'cause I thought I could do much
better than my dad.
But I wasn't passionate about
selling beer or liquor but this
wine thing was super interesting
to me and by the time I was 18
somewhere between 16 and 18
I went completely all-in.
Scary to think back how
much I learned about
wine as a teenager.
And I decided that I wanted to
open up 4,000 wine shops all
across America.
Eventually build a big business,
sell it and buy
the New York Jets.
Which is my career ambition.
When I was 18 even though I only
spent about 30 minutes of my
life on a
computer at that point.
I was in college.
And I went to my friends dorm
room and I heard the dial-up
internet sound
for the first time.
And in 1994 about 14 minutes
into surfing the web I ended up
on a bulletin board in AOL that
was selling baseball cards and
I realized that I could sell
shit through this machine.
24 months later I launched one
of the first three e-commerce
wine businesses in America
called WineLibrary.com and that
became my career.
Spent $15,000 on
building that website.
I was still at university and so
nobody back home at the liquor
store knew what to do with it.
So on that $15,000 investment
the wine e-commerce site in the
first two years of operations
sold less than $2000 in wine.
I don't know how many of you
have a Soviet father but
Sasha Vaynerchuk was not
happy with the ROI.
In 1998, I came home and
took over the business.
And from 1998 until 2003 in a
five-year window I grew my dad's
business from a $3 million to
a $65 million a year business.
I did it on the religion that
allows me the humbleness to sit
in front of you guys here today.
Which is when you have no
money and the business just for
context did $3 million in
revenue, 10% gross profit.
So $300,000 before expenses.
Luckily, Sasha didn't pay
anybody anything but still there
was really no money.
The only way to build that
business as quickly as I did
especially in a time when the
internet was quite immature and
there wasn't the kind of user
base that we all have now,
there was no venture capital.
There was no M&amp;A activity.
I built it because I made every
penny of my advertising work
like hundred dollar bill.
How I did that in 1996 was I
launched an e-commerce site when
nobody did that.
In 1997 I launch an email
newsletter that had 200,000
people on it that had 91% open
rates and 55% click through to
add to cart button because in
1997 nobody was doing email
marketing in the US market or
any market for that matter.
The day Google Adwords came out
in 2000 I bought the word wine
and I owned it nine
months for five cents a click.
Basically my career is very
different than the legendary
status of this agency which is
all of my career in the first
5 to 7 years was predicated on
the one thing that is my religion.
It's a smart thing and a thing
that I believe in my heart to
say in this room, I truly
believe that creative is the
variable of success.
The creative is the difference
between selling 1,000 cases of
that wine or one
bottle of that wine.
And I think that is
way will be forever.
My problem, my excitement, my
debates, my passion, my hours
are spent on the fact that I
believe most people deployed
creative into a gap of
attention that is overpriced.
My career was built on buying
attention at a very low cost.
E-commerce, email marketing and
Google Adwords in '97, 2000 was
grossly underpriced by the
creative and advertising shops
of the world and
by the businesses
and startups of the world.
And that's why I was able to
build such a big business.
I continued that path with
banner retargeting when that
wasn't a thing and my career
took a really different turn and
probably started my
path to the seat
in 2006 when YouTube came out.
YouTube came out, I thought
it was going to be a big deal.
And within four months
of YouTube being
alive I started a wine show.
And every day for five years I
sat in front of a camera for 20
minutes and drank
four bottles of wine.
(laughter)
It was a good gig.
In the first year and a half of
YouTube, 2006 to 2007 1/2 very
few people watched it.
There was not a single
video that had a million views.
It was building.
By 2008, I was selling hundreds
of cases of wine per episode if
I reviewed the wines carefully
and properly and it was the
first time in my career that I
was selling stuff where there
was no paid distribution.
It was completely predicated
on the content itself and the
organic distribution
of the channel.
A few months later Google
bought YouTube for $1.6 billion.
That was the point
where my career changed.
I read an article that Ron Conway
angel investor was set to
make $25 million on his $50,000
investment and it was the first
time I realized this gift of
being about right about e-com
and Google Adwords and email and
Google and YouTube it has to pay
off more than selling a
couple more cases of
Bordeaux or Burgundy.
And so I promised myself the
next time I felt it, the next
time I felt that feeling that
is so dictated the success of my
life that I would invest.
I went to SXSW the following
March because I wanted to learn
more about this web 2.0
thing that was happening.
There was an app everybody was
making fun of called Twitter.
I thought it reminded me a
lot of early email marketing.
I became very friendly with
the founders and a couple months
later I invested in Twitter
at a $50 million valuation.
A couple weeks later I
made my first business video.
It was called, "Facebook should
be worried about Twitter."
I explained why I thought
Twitter was a very exciting
thing and why this new
force Facebook should be paying
attention to it.
It led to Mark Zuckerberg's team
reaching out to me, I flew out
to Palo Alto and
spoke to their company.
Gave a talk about
consumer behavior
and the attention graph.
Mark luckily agreed
with a lot of stuff.
We had dinner and a couple weeks
later I bought a shit load of
stock from his parents.
A week later I came home to
New York had my first lunch with
David Karp, decided that Tumblr
was gonna be a big deal.
Three months later
I invested in Tumblr.
So as an investor I'll probably
never do better than my
first three investments.
I've gone on to invest in
BirchBox and Uber and BuddyMedia
and Wildfire and a lot of good
things and have done quite well
but back then I understood that
all those platforms attention
was underpriced.
It's the way that I know that
any brand in the world that you
work with definitely now the UK,
in the US and many other markets
if they are trying to sell
something sneakers, a soda,
a piece of candy, clothing to a
15 to 25-year-old 95% of the
ideas in this room, at Vayner and
many other rooms are not going to
work because were going to
deploy stories in places where
15 to 25-year-olds are not
spending their attention.
I'll use Mondelez, Sour Patch
Kids was probably one of our
most interesting
case studies in US.
The brand manager literally
almost got fired for doing what
I recommended to be done which
was in 2014 they spent all of
their money on a commercial that
was running on Spike television
because they were trying to
reach 15 to 25-year-olds.
Business was down 7 1/2%.
In 2015, when we took over the
business we moved every single
dollar to only
Instagram and Snapchat.
There was no reporting
to justify the spend.
Mondelez's modeling mix didn't
prove that moving those dollars
to those channels
was gonna do anything.
The first nine months of our
activities because the reporting
wasn't back yet, the brand
manager was literally on the
process of being fired
out of the organization.
When it was all said and done
last year's Sour Patch Kids in
the US had the fastest growth of
any candy brand
in the last 10 years.
Because I don't know if you know
that this is a crazy fucking
thought but 15 to 25-year-olds
spend their attention in
Instagram and Snapchat.
We have right now in marketing
and just all over the world a
stunning disrespect for
attention and a gross
overwhelming, overwhelming
respect for bullshit metrics,
headlines, awards and a ton a
shit that has nothing to do it
with actually selling product.
Now, now.
Thank you my man.
Now.
That being said it is an
interesting thing because I'll
say this and this is super
important to say here because
I think context is everything.
I am in advertising now for
the last seven years really I've
been running the company
for the last five years.
Just for context since you're in
this world I've grown the agency
from 30 to 650 people from three
to $100 million in revenue.
No M-and-A, no cash infusion.
And I'm still selling
something nobody wants.
Nobody wants our creative.
Nobody even thinks of
VaynerMedia as a creative shop.
And I know enough,
I don't know much about
the advertising world, right?
If you told me you'd give me
$50 billion right now if I could
name the CEO of your company or
any other company I would not be
able to do that.
I don't know it.
When I go to Cannes I feel super
out of place because I have no
idea what the fuck
anybody is talking about.
I don't know the
space very well.
I mean that.
And so the reason I just did
that little rant was I do know
enough as a matter of fact I
even use it your guy's name in
some of my speeches because
I know this is a special place.
I know this is one of those
places that is so well known for
their great creative and
things of that nature.
And I am funny guy because I
speak so much about creative
being subjective because it is.
It is subjective when it's you
and it's me and I run Dove
and you're the creative lead for
Wieden and it's just you and I
and we decide that this
idea versus that idea
is what goes on television.
That is 100% subjective.
Just so everybody knows.
It's 100 fucking
percent subjective.
Now when it goes into real
life it becomes not subjective.
The market decides.
However, what bothers me is it
made a lot of sense from 1955 to
2010 to do it that way.
Because you didn't have the
ability to scale your IP prior
to putting it in the market.
For every "Just Do It" and
"MasterCard Priceless" there
have been thousands, in this
room, this is so interesting to
me, this is funny I haven't
really spoken too much at shops
like this.
Creative shops in general and
definitely not at this level.
In this room, there have been 5
to 11 ideas at individual levels
that literally were they game
changing idea for a business
that never saw the day of life
because of the way creative and
brands work
together in a 2016 world.
Because you were too junior and
the senior person decided not
that idea, this idea. Right?
Or because when you presented
it, the brand manager and you
guys I assume this is how
you guys think about it
it's fun for me to watch.
As I have mapped what we do for
a living I look at the people
that make the decision to run
shit and I'm like this is the
craziest shit I've ever seen.
These are actual business
operators which by the way as I
think you guys are getting I
didn't grow drawing and fucking
being an artist.
I'm a salesman.
I love brand managers I love
people who give a shit about
margin and fucking stacking
end caps and selling shit.
That is my religion.
I love them.
But do I think they are the
right person to make a judgment
call on a creative execution?
I do not.
And I see it every single day.
And so the whole model to me is
fundamentally broken because I
have the ability,
and the luxury honestly,
to come from outside eyes.
I don't know any different.
I didn't know why awards and
headlines meant so much in this
world until I realized ah,
that's how agencies get talent
and get new clients.
Of course that
makes so much sense.
I don't understand why media
buying agencies tell all their
clients to do programmatic ad
buying when there's literally no
worse piece of fucking
advertising in the world than a
banner on a fucking website
when the whole world is going to
mobile and you don't even see
the banner ad because on the
bottom left hand corner, below
the fold on womenswomens.org.
(laughter)
But then I'm like oh, I see
because that's the highest
profit margin for
Group M and Digitas.
That's why they push it.
As you start getting in it
if you don't understand the
historical context, if you
don't, if you're just not
romantic about the way it was
you start understanding pieces
of this industry.
Here's the punchline problem, or
the opportunity just depends on
where you sit on this issue,
we're going into a day and age
where technology is catching up
to two fundamental things that
are going to matter to everybody
in this room and everybody
outside of this building.
Which is data is catching up to
justify and understand what the
ROI is of things more
and more every single day.
If you really understand.
I really nice advantage.
I live my life really more in
Silicon Valley than I do in
Madison Avenue and so for
example I'm an investor in many
startups right now that
already have pilot programs with
Coca-Cola and Green Mountain
Coffee and Procter &amp; Gamble
where their packages are
"smartified" and you can
actually start justifying and
understanding the whole funnel
of the transaction.
You can start quantifying
some of the behaviors.
It's gonna be fucked, we're
going to understand what we do
for a living here more than ever
before in a ten year period.
And I'm not talking about direct
response, I'm talking about
branding and how it justifies
controled test with
smart packaging.
Really understanding
the ROI of things.
At the same token and I think
you guys know this every single
day technology's moving into a
world where they're blocking
advertising because advertising
my friends for the last 70 years
has done one thing more than
it's on anything else;
It's stolen time from
the end consumer.
Advertising for the last 70
years has been built to not let
you do what you actually wanted
to do, stop you and then tell
you about something.
You're watching a show, and all
of a sudden it stops and we try
to sell you fucking beer. Right?
You're reading an article you
turn the next page you want to
finish your fucking article, no.
We're gonna give you a
full page of a fucking car.
Right?
This is what advertising
has done and online too.
You go to ESPN.com, we're
not going to let you read the
article the whole fucking page
is going to be taken out by an
Acura fucking car riding at me.
Right?
And so what we have is we
have the world of advertising
stealing our time while when you
look at DVR did if you
actually understand.
One of the great mistakes of
my career is I passed on
Uber's angel round twice.
Very friendly with the founding
team passed twice invested the
next round because it came to
New York and I understood holy
shit Uber doesn't sell
transportation, Uber sells time.
The reason people take Ubers is
even the perception of the car
being there, the perception
of those five minutes if you
actually look at your own
behavior and I don't know your
financial status but you will
be stunned no matter where your
financial status is the world
if you look at big data how much
people spend on time,
convenience when they can't even
afford it because
it's important to them.
And if you look at what
advertising has been built on
it's been stealing
time versus vice versa.
So when I think about all of
the digital marketing that
everybody's doing.
And how much of it is predicated
on time stealing in a desktop
environment when oh, I don't
know if you heard this is the
only fucking way we're going
to consume the internet, right?
And it's happening on an
everyday basis and all those
tactics don't work here,
I'm fascinated by that stuff.
And look the other thing,
and look I is assume this is a
television shop from
what I know and things.
Listen, I do not understand
how everybody in this room as a
commonsense human being doesn't
understand that television
commercials are in major, major
friction against the market
right now.
People are not consuming as
much television, commercials.
It's so funny all my TV creative
shop friends CEOs that I meet at
things they're like,
"Gary TV consumption
is through the roof."
I'm like, "No shit.
"Everybody is
watching 'Breaking Bad'.
"Everybody's watching fucking
'House of Card' and everybody's
"fucking watching 'Game of
Thrones' but who the fuck is
"watching the commercials?"
Fast forwarding globally has
declined last year for the first
time during DVR and TiVo and
those things because the new
behavior and you know this
because you actually do it as a
human, maybe not as a marketer
and as a creative but as a human
you do the second you're
watching something and a
commercial comes
on you grab this.
Everybody loves to talk about
live sports commercials being
this great thing, I don't
understand why people don't look
at the most basic data which
is the singular biggest lift in
Twitter activity is during
global sporting events when they
go to commercials.
Because you know after something
happens you grab your phone and
you want to tell everybody your
opinion on LeBron James' dunk or
your opinion on that
big match or the big fight or
whatever you just saw.
So what happens is your
attention's here while some Jeep
goes up the mountain over there.
My friends, listen, listen, I
have no interest in coming in
here and saying oh what you do I
just want you to know one thing
if you go look at what happened
in the 1950s to the early '60s
when the society switched from
radio to television it is an
absolute preview to what
is happening as we
live and breathe today.
This is the television.
And the television is the radio.
And you do it every single day.
And more importantly go walk
outside and watch the 40 and 50
and 60-year-olds do it too.
This is not a
13-year-old girl phenomenon.
And social media just for kicks
and giggles just to settle this
fucking conversation
once and for all
there is no social media.
It is a slang term that
somebody came up with.
It's a term that we use for the
current state of the internet.
And if you believe in this thing
just kicks and giggles this is
just data 53% of all of our
attention, 53% of all of our
attention on this device,
this is added up time on apps.
Not opinion
is spent on social networks.
When you start looking at social
media as the current state of
the internet where people's
attention actually it a gets a
lot harder to disrespect it.
But the skill that sits so
heavily in this room
doesn't go away.
It just has to, in my opinion,
one man's opinion, it just has
the change its context to where
the stories are being told.
It's funny when I started my
company I started hiring fancy
creatives, creative directors
from this place and Droga 5 and
72 and Sunny and all
these fuckin' places, right?
All of the creatives hated me
because they would go watch two
videos and they'd hear
something like this.
What they didn't realize what I
believe is the following: How
many of you in this room by show
of hands I just want to know
have seen the Extra gum
commercial that's run on YouTube
or Facebook the two-minute
version of where the guy draws
the love notes in the
Extra gum wrappers?
Please raise your
hand for my own context.
Raise it high.
I want to see how many.
All right, five.
(laughter)
I get it.
Respect.
It's probably why
I saw it at first too.
We're on that gum business too.
So that was fascinating to me.
I think you guys will
get a kick of the story.
In the US there's a video you
can see it online they ran a 30
second spot version of it for 7
1/2 months and the business and
again maybe listen this is very
honest truth I do stereotype
that a lot of agencies actually
don't care about selling stuff.
But here's the good news, I've
come to learn that a lot of my
clients don't actually don't
want to sell stuff either.
People behaviors predicate
on the personal interest.
Of course you want to do
award-winning work, it's good
for your career.
Of course my people want
headlines, my clients they want
headlines because
then they get promoted.
Everything's backwards.
People are just humans and
they're reverse engineering in
their own vested interest
and they should, I'm not mad.
It's just life.
It's just true.
Anyway 30 second spot nine
months decline, decline in sales
they made a full version of it
they go, "You know, what the
hell let's put it on Facebook."
The one minute and 53 second
version of it is a far more
compelling story.
It didn't have to fit into the
box of a system that was built
in 19-fucking-65.
And the person that was a
creative and the writer actually
got to tell their fucking story
the way it was meant to be told.
And you know I don't know if you
know but there's a lot of people
on Facebook.
This whole scale thing
is really intriguing.
There's plenty of fucking scale.
There's more scale on Facebook
every day of the week than there
is on any number one television
show in the world times 10.
Just raw data, unemotional.
So remarkable thing happened.
I don't know, just stunning,
funny things happens because,
I don't know, stories
in video form, work.
I think we'll all agree.
Because it was actually
consumed, because it was
actually told as a story in it's
full complete way and because
people have the ability to pass
things on on Facebook, I can't
take my TV and throw it to
somebody, the product exploded.
The video exploded.
It went secondarily on YouTube
which I think now has 15 million
views or something absurd.
And the business has been up
double digits every day since 30
day after they put up on
Facebook for the last
seven months.
Everything you do
for a living works.
My argument to the whole God
damn marketplace is you're
telling the stories in places
where people aren't anymore.
It's declining by the minute.
Do I think people
randomly catch commercials?
Of course.
Do I think it is
massively overpriced attention?
Yes I do.
Why is billboard pricing
globally, in the world, up 12%
when every single person here
when on the bus or in a taxi or
not the primary driver is
looking at their telephone.
Can you tell me with any fucking
common sense that impressions on
billboard are more
valuable today than
they were 10 years ago?
Absolutely not.
It's the same reason I love
Super Bowl commercials,
real quick.
On the flip side, I think the
Super Bowl commercial may be the
single most underpriced asset in
the world of attention, period.
In the US I think it was like
$5 or $6 million for a
spot this year.
I've recommended ABI and
Mondelez and Pepsi and all of my
clients to spend as much is $25
million on a spot because every
single person in
America watches it.
Everybody, whether they watched
on YouTube before or they watch
it when it airs.
Now the creative a lot of times
people are doing things for the
sake of winning.
Instead of the sake of
selling stuff but that's a whole
different conversation.
And really and honestly, I don't
even have a lot of passion about
that because I do think it is
subjective and actually I'm
sorry I got off this tangent.
I want to go back because I
think this is the part that may
my creative's finally like
me which has been a relief.
If you're a team of ECD, a CD,
and an ACD and you got a client
and you got a strategist and
you got an account person that
thinks they know what the deal
is and everybody is jamming, I
just love the idea of being able
to be in a place where if you
got an idea for
Trident gum, right?
That all four of you can see the
day of life of your story, you
can run it at scale on Facebook
you can get feedback from actual
consumers not focus groups where
we put them in weird rooms and
show them animatronics or
whatever the fuck you call it
and everyone's like
"Yeah, real good."
It makes no sense.
Every time I look at this stuff
I really, again maybe I'm too
foreign, maybe I'm wrong
which is very possible.
I've been that before.
Let's go back to this story
and then I'll keep jumping.
This is how I roll.
My first meeting first one ever
first one, start the company we
land Campbell's Soup.
I'm gonna put them on Facebook.
They're like, "What's Facebook?"
I'm like, "This is perfect.
"This is my world."
I go into my first meeting.
It's a V-8 juice, you
guys have V-8 here?
Good V-8 fucking juice meeting.
I sit down, it's an
IMC or something.
All the fucking
agency partners, right?
I sit down.
I'm super pumped.
I promise myself I'm going to
shut up which is rare for me I
need to learn I need to
shut my fucking mouth.
I'm gonna listen and learn.
So I don't say a god
damn thing and here we go.
First comes up the PR company.
Just a recap, "Great news, we
got 987 trillion impressions for
"you last month," because they
got a mention on Huffington Post
seventh page in, bottom
left-hand corner but you know
they give the credit for
the entire monthly reach of
HuffPo.com for their metrics.
So that started off tough
but 800 drillion impressions,
everybody claps.
Then somebody comes up, whether
creative shop or somebody else
they did something, they showed
some creative and they go,
"Great news, Millard Brown,"
I had never heard that word
before, "Millard Brown says
it's the greatest shit
"that ever happened."
Yay, everybody claps. Right?
The activation agency comes up
and goes, "Great news we went to
"the NCAA tournament and we gave
out a bunch of fucking soup and
"we got 700 drillion
people to try it."
I'm like this is
an amazing world.
Somehow they figured out how
many people actually tried the
soup by giving out samples yet
every event I've ever given to
all the fucking samples are on
the ground but cool unbelievable
7 million people I tried
fucking V-8 soup. Great.
Now I'm getting antsy because
this is why failed
everything in school.
I basically just went to
the last page which said the
business is down 19%.
So finally four different people
present, the digital shop comes
up and honestly you
know what's funny?
I will take as much as I just
railed on television commercials
if you call it that I will take
a TV commercial over 90% of the
bullshit digital
shit that people sell.
Pre-roll, banner, takeover
stuff that nobody wants.
I would call those
impressions that are negatives.
When we going to start, by the
way real quick just as a side
note, as a tidbit.
Can we start debating the
value of an impression?
Why is everybody
predicated on the impression.
Impressions can be bad.
Awareness can be bad.
Everybody knew who
Hitler was, that wasn't good.
Impressions can be bad.
I will never buy a Samsung
product because they kept doing
pop up banner ads on ESPN.com
that annoyed me so much and by
the way you guys know this on
mobile devices those
little x's are small.
And our thumbs are big.
So those hundred impressions
that I by accident clicked into
seven times back at
Group M everyone's like 7%.
(high five's himself)
(laughter)
Meanwhile, I will never buy a
Samsung, I mean literally the
seventh time I called
my wife and said,
"I swear, when I die
you can remarry.
"You could do whatever the
fuck you want but nobody in his
"family while I'm
alive buys Samsung."
(laughter)
It's true.
I finally raise my hand to the
Campbell's meeting I go, listen,
I come from an
entrepreneur land.
I come from running
my own businesses.
I'm missing something.
I know this is $1 billion
companies I don't want to deploy
my hundred million dollars
business mentality but I've got
to ask I've just sat through
this meeting and I know and I
was I'm self-aware I was like
look I know this is going to be
who the fuck is this
guy and what the fuck?
Right?
I have to ask
because I have to learn.
How can we have such a
compelling meeting for 45
minutes where everybody did
everything right and why is the
business down 19%?
And no joke this is my
first corporate America meeting
advertising big brand meeting
everybody in their goes
"Yeah, fucking confusing."
(laughter)
And I was like holy shit.
I literally said could we debate
the metrics that you
guys score on?
And that was it that was the
beginning of a six year period
where I've come to
realize, you can't.
Once the organization decides to
accept ACE testing, do you guys
know this ACE testing thing?
My ABI client does that.
They make a commercial and then
they have to run it
through an ACE test.
Which is something out of a 1927
sci-fi movie and that justifies
what sees television.
I know I'm saying
it wrong Animanic?
Yeah.
Pictures, stuff
that makes no sense.
It's stuff that makes no sense.
And so, I don't know I'm
confused but not confused
meaning there's a reason, you
know because I spend a lot of
time on startup land I would
tell Dove and Johnson &amp; Johnson
clients, I'm like hey you
gotta look out for Method.
Hey, you gotta look
out for Honest Company.
These things are happening
and they would laugh them out.
When Dollars Shave Club's video,
bless you,
went viral I think
that's like television.
That is a lot of video views.
I called Gillette people because
I was very friendly with the
former CEO and I said you
got to take a look at this.
They literally, this is not a
joke, they literally laughed me
off the call.
And now of course there's
the Gillette Shave Club.
Right?
I don't understand why we look
at the marketing behaviors of an
Airbnb or an Uber or all the
startups that really go from 0
to $300, $800, $900 million in
sales and they act one way and
then we all sit on pieces of
businesses that act a different
way and they
continue to decline.
They're all declining.
Everybody's like how?
And it's the same thing that
happens in American politics.
I kept making videos I'm like
Obama's gonna win, Obama's gonna
win, Obama's gonna win 'cause he
did surgical digital marketing
and everybody's like no.
And then he won and now
everyone's like Trump,
how did this happen?
Because he actually went to
where people's attention is.
It's just attention.
My friends, the only thing
you're in here, the only
business you're in
here is attention
and then your part starts.
And then your part starts.
And then is your story, is your
copy, is your art compelling
enough to sell?
But my creatives are happy with
me because we have a process now
where we do 4 to 7 commercials
for a client, test them at scale
and then whatever wins you know
the person that actually wants
to buy stuff reacts to, that
gets to the light of day but can
you imagine, can you imagine
what's happened in our four
walls for the creatives that
have worked in shops like this
for the last 10 years to
actually have their idea see the
day of light because we also
built an internal
production house.
We drive down the costs.
There's a way to make a
$400,000 video for $190,000.
You hack at it.
You find the inefficiencies in
what the market's done and all
of a sudden when you do that and
all of a sudden you convince a
client to spend media
efficiently there's a couple
dollars left over for creative.
All of a sudden you got all four
stories and then interesting
things happen, for example we
ran a piece of content that
starred African-American
families and then targeted
African-American families on
Facebook and a remarkable
thing happened, it worked.
In the US there's a
channel called BET.
African-Americans watch more of
that because they star in it.
We run Asian-Americans on
certain stuff and they watch it
because when you see yourself
within the creative it works.
And on television
everything's vanilla.
Because you have to make it for
everybody and then every slogan
is like just do it.
Or for the good of it or yeah.
Everything's fucking vanilla.
I couldn't imagine, as I've
gotten to know you guys better
this is the only world you
should give a shit about.
This is the world that gives
you the opportunity to do you.
Instead of complete vanilla
blunt wide objects that strip
all the shit that you
have in your heart.
So, I don't know.
I think the golden era of
creative's coming and I think it
comes in the form of Facebook
and it makes me laugh because
all my creatives hat have
been doing it for 12 to 20 years
poo-poo it and think it's shit
and think it's third tier and
fucking bush league because they
don't know what the fuck they're
talking about. That's why.
And so I don't know it's going
to be fun to watch of the next
10 years. I know this.
I know that we've never seen the
friction between big brands and
their media buying agencies like
we've seen over the last three
years because they're starting
to wake up and realize the two
biggest margin areas for media
buying agencies are television
and programmatic ad buying
and ironically that's the only
fucking thing that
they tell them to do.
I know that.
And I know that that's going
to change where dollars get
allocated and how they're
going to get allocated.
And I know that we have a whole
generation of people that are
not going to be rewarded for
doing the thing that doesn't
get them fired.
I'm religious about attention.
I couldn't imagine selling
something to an 18-year-old in
America and not spending 80% of
my money on Snapchat creative.
Why?
They don't spend
another minute anywhere else.
Why in the world?
I don't give a shit
what your reports say or
what you grew up with.
The market is the market is
the market and I'm telling you
especially if you love
advertising, please go study
what happened from 1955 to 1965
in the US market
I can speak for.
I'm not quite as sure here of
the timing or if that's exactly
what happened but
I'm sure it is.
Because when the collective of
our society's attention shifts
platforms, carnage
and opportunity
happen at the same time.
The four biggest beer brands in
America all collapsed because
they were romantic about radio.
Because there was creatives at
the shops that loved writing
copy for radio and didn't give a
shit about this 30 second video
bullshit on this black-and-white
thing that nobody's gonna watch.
That's why.
That's exactly what's
happening right now.
And here's the punchline and
I'll go in to Q&amp;A please go
to any detail.
I did talk a lot about social
but if you want to talk about
Musically or Anchor or Snapchat
or whatever you
like to talk about.
It was romance that put
everybody out of business.
And the thing that bothers
me about romance is it
lacks practicality.
I hate when I go and speak of
these companies or agencies and
they go "He's a disruptor," and
"He's a real disruptor here he
is Gary," and I get up
there and I'm like,
"I'm not a fucking disruptor.
"I'm the most practical
fucking guy in this room."
You know what I think is
disruptive, trying to sell a
25-year-old in 2016 something
through a fucking
television commercial.
That's disruptive,
that's fucking insanity.
And you know what bothers me the
most, and I'll end with this,
you know this when you walk
out of this fucking hall.
You know this.
It's what you do every
fucking day as a normal human.
It's what your parents
are doing every day.
You see it right in your face
but because this is what you do
for a living you trick yourself
when you walk
through these doors.
That's wrong.
It just is.
Thank you.
(applause)
What is your name, my man?
- [Man] What's the
average age of your employees?
- The last the average age
of VaynerMedia, so we're 650
people, I would say the
average age is probably 28.
And only in the last 150
employees did we even hire
anybody over 35 because so
there's a couple of advantages,
I don't run on any margin.
That helps me do good work.
I can make $400,000 videos for
$180 because
I don't run any margin.
The reason I don't run any
margin just to get to the real
punchline for you guys, I think
you might find it fascinating is
I want to build a private equity
business on top of my agency, so
I still want by the New York
Jets I just don't want to open a
4,000 liquor stores.
My belief is that we, all of
us in advertising, I guess is
Ogilvy the 50% of my
money I'm wasting.
I truly in my heart
think it's 90% now.
And in that arbitrage
I think I can buy brands.
And market them the right
way and make a lot of money.
If you know who 3G the private
equity firm that bought ABI and
bought Heinz, I want to
build the reverse of that.
What they're good at is they buy
a business and they strip it.
They bought Burger King
and had 1400 employees
and now they have 30.
They do that kind of shit.
They print on both sides of the
paper, the CEOs flies fucking
coach middle seat.
That's what they do.
Cool.
As an immigrant I
respect the shit out of it.
My whole career has
been predicated on
growing businesses.
We're young because I couldn't
afford to pay anybody, you know.
We've grown a lot, we did
$3,000,000 48 months ago.
You can't afford this kind of
talent on that kind
of top line revenue.
Over the last 15, 18 months
we've started being able to
afford people and it's
been super interesting.
And it's gotten older but the
truth is we just hired our chief
creative officer, right?
Started literally nine days ago.
He was at Crispin
Porter for six years.
I spent six months trying to
find the person and this is the
order of what mattered to me
first emotional intelligence.
When I tell you that I don't
respect talent it
would upset you.
It's stunning when I run my
business how secondary pure
talent is to people skills.
This notion that some creative
is so fucking special that they
can be a douche bag and fuck
up the entire place is the
stupidest shit I've
ever heard in my life.
And I'm very unpopular in
tech-land, I did it again at
South-By where I was
like fuck Steve Jobs.
I don't want to run a business
where being mean brings
the best out of.
I don't give a shit if
you're a creative genius.
Fucking act like a
normal person you asshole.
(laughter)
So first I'm always scared of
that we have unbelievable my C,
CIO, but he's really our COO my
brother is my CEO partner but
James Orsini he was the CFO
and CEO of Saatchi &amp; Saatchi and
he's been in that ecosystem for
25 years, when he came and saw
our voluntary turnover rate he
was like, "What are you doing?"
He knew our salaries were in
line it wasn't
anything like that.
I'm like what we're doing is
we're an HR driven organization
because I believe
continuity trumps everything.
Continuity you know it's just
like sports a team that stays
together usually beats a team
with superstars that were put
together for one season.
And I believe that.
And I love continuity at Vayner.
We have enormous continuity
already for a young company and
I want to keep it
forever because I give a shit.
Rhys is now living in London,
she's going to be part of the
London team because four years
ago when she started working at
Vayner I'm like
"What do you want?"
She's like "I want
to be in London."
I'm like, "Cool, if we ever go
there, you'll go there,"
and then I did it.
And by the way, I don't care
if you're driven by money or by
work-life balance or by creative
output I individually at 650
care about what you care about
and I also know when you get
married you're going to
care about different shit.
We're an HR driven organization.
I needed to find a CCO that
understood that so
that was a challenge.
Especially when you're looking
for them and I was looking for
somebody more like this
because I wanted to taste what a
seasoned veteran from a Wieden
from a Crispin looked like.
What did that feel
like internally?
Number two I wanted somebody who
is religious about attention and
not the platform he or
she was storytelling on.
The level of romance in this
industry of which platform your
storytelling on is laughable
at best and insane at worst.
Like really?
You'd really rather have it on
fucking BBC during a segment
then have 50 times more people
in the world see it, really?
Why?
Because you were told that.
Because that's what's
rewarded in the current moment.
The problem is, what pisses
me off is, I have so much
compassion for
everybody, you guys are young.
You really think the industry is
going to reward that
in 7 to 10 years?
You think as the Ubers and the
Airbnbs become the Mastercards
and the Procter &amp; Gambles
that they're going to want your
talent when you
were that religious?
So I sit on panels with all
these hot shot young creatives
I'm like, "Dude, you're fucking
"you're on the record
you're fucked.
"You're dead."
What are you doing, right?
So we're young but
quickly growing older.
Cliché right?
To me, it's really really
not an age thing truly.
Because I was stunned by how
much Steve Babcock's religion
was about wherever.
I think if you find the purest
form creative that has more
practical business DNA then
just somebody who wants to
get their nut off.
There's just so many creatives
that just want to get it done.
Because TV's where the budget is
right now and I always wanted to
blow up a rock so they're like
fuck it that's where
I want to be.
If you're religious about
getting your story out to the
world and you actually have any
practitioner-ship understanding
of what's happening right now
there is no debate
for that person.
We're getting older but that
doesn't scare me because I'll be
honest with you I can think of 3
to 4 strategy creative people in
the organization that are lets
call it 40 and above who I think
are more in tune to what's
actually going on than a lot of
my 26-year-olds.
A lot of my 26-year-olds still
grew up wanting to
be on Adage's top.
One of my kids ran up to me he's
like, "We made GE," GE's been a
brand that's gotten a lot of
credit for a lot of work that
we've done over
the last five years.
He's like, "We made it on
AdAge's top 10 hit list."
And I'm like,
"The fuck is that?"
He's like, "I've always wanted
to be on it," and I was pumped
for him because I grew up
wanting to the in the
Wine Spectator and
I have empathy.
If this is your craft, if
this is what you always knew,
If you're dad or mom did this.
I don't want to destroy that,
I just want people to understand
it's dangerous to be, the
quickest way to go out of
business is to be romantic
about how you make your money.
It's the quickest way.
Listen, guys I wish, I didn't
get to tell the full story,
I built my library on direct-mail,
outdoor, radio local television,
full-page ads in the New York
Times and Wall Street Journal.
I wish that
marketing didn't change.
I had it figured out.
I had 1.2 million
followers on Twitter.
Do you know how sad I am
that Twitter's fucking
losing attention?
Fucking work seven years
answering all your
fucking questions.
I'm pissed but it doesn't
change the fact that
that's what is happening.
And so if I have to stay up 'til
three in the morning to figure
out how Musically works because
60 million, 60 million people
are using it monthly from 0
seven months ago and if I want
to sell a 16-year-old
something, I need to know.
Just need to know.
My man? What's your name?
Scott.
- [Scott] Do you think
social platforms (inaudible).
- 100%. Yeah.
I will literally walk back in
here for years now and be like
you guys are doing
Facebook you fucking idiots.
100%. Absolutely.
It's why I've been such a big
advocate of Facebook because out
of all the people I've ever
met my life, forget about in
business, in my life I truly
believe that Mark Zuckerberg
understands EQ more than any.
It's so funny because the movie
really did a number for him
in a good way.
They made him,
the whole story is,
he didn't build Facebook
for a girl.
Hollywood is so
fucking interesting.
Anyway.
(laughter)
His emotional intelligence
is so extreme,
it's how we became
friends back then.
It's how I got in.
Because he was able to
tell this guy gets it.
In a way that he, you know?
The reason the algorithm was
so brilliant is the only thing
Zucks gives a shit
about is attention.
It's why he bought Instagram.
This is good, Piers Morgan
a London guy, good.
I was on CNN the day Facebook
bought Instagram for $1 billion
because six months
earlier News Corp.
another one they had "The
Daily" remember "The Daily"?
I did a show on a "The Daily"
once a week about business stuff
and tech stuff.
I had a prediction show at the
end of the year and I predicted
Facebook would buy Instagram so
four months later they buy it.
And I get to be on CNN
with Piers and talk about it.
And I go that they stole it.
And I don't know if you remember
this, this is two years ago.
Instagram was 551 days old.
And they spent $1 billion on it.
People lost their shit.
A lot of people in America and
the world didn't even know what
Instagram was yet and $1
billion is a lot of money.
And it was a lot of money two
years ago compared to today,
just the way the world works.
And I go on the show
and go he stole it.
I get out of the studio and
there's thousands of people
saying I'm an idiot on Twitter.
I saved every one of them
when WhatApp was bought for $18
billion ironically when I'm on
vacation in Turks and Caicos
with my wife and the first day I
laid on the beach pulled up all
those tweets and replied to
every single person on Twitter
and said, "Now what bitch?"
But the reason I predicted that
Zucks bought Instagram and the
reason Mark Zuckerberg, think
about this guys, Mark tried to
buy Snapchat for $3
billion 18 months ago.
The one thing he understands
better than anybody executing
right now is
attention is the only asset.
And so he keeps trying
to buy the thing that
will arbitrage him out.
If Facebook did not own
Instagram today, there'd be a
lot more friction and tension
about it's health but because
they have another
five years behind that.
And if they fucking had
Snapchat fucking forget it.
Right?
I think Evan had the benefit of
being rich so he didn't sell and
two he had good intuition.
And he believes in attention
too if you look at the way the
product's built on both those
front this what I yelled about
Twitter in 2011.
I'm like change the firehose.
People's attention
is gonna go away.
Create an algorithm.
These algorithms work
because they keep us on it.
There's a reason Google created
a promotion tab on Gmail.
The data was going in the wrong
direction 'cause we'd
ruined email.
So yes, I do think that we, me
I spend every minute trying to
ruin Snapchat and Musically.
Yes, I do.
I think that's what happens
unless these platforms are smart
enough to create different ad
units that don't steal our time
or don't push
stuff we don't want.
Facebook wins because their data
is so insane that I believe that
if advertisers actually got the
shit together we could save our
industry because I actually want
root beer and Lionel Richie and
New York Jets ads in my Facebook
and what's really interesting is
Facebook is trying to figure
this out so many of the media
buying companies are such douche
bags they want to buy Facebook
in TV like behavior instead of
what they should be doing which
is creating 25 different
cohorts, then giving it to you
and now if you know that you're
going after a single mom with
three kids that all like
basketball that live in Ireland
think about what you're going
to make creatively versus
if you're going after moms.
Think about that.
Think about the creative freedom
and volume of different stories
we could tell.
Think about when I just did that
for you versus going moms where
your head went.
How many more things you could
be doing, the kind of stories
you can be telling.
Yes, I do but I do think at
least Mark as such a young CEO
of such a big company will be
doing behavior for a long time
that may educate future
platforms and it'll be
interesting to see
where it shifts.
Absolutely I do not think
social is on a pedestal, if I was
here in 2000 I'd be like
guys this Google Adwords thing,
search, right?
I'm always trying to put
myself out of business.
Every day.
I'm always everyday waking up
and saying is this is why I'm
heavily after Twitter was what
built me it's where I came from
for this world.
It's been the thing that I've
been railing on the most for the
last 12 months even though those
are my best friends, even though
I made millions of dollars on
it, even though I'm sitting on
millions of dollars in stock.
My reputation of being right is
the only asset and I think it's
completely fucking broken.
My man? What is your name?
- [Will] Will.
- Will.
- [Will] (inaudible) media
agency (inaudible) media buying
whatsoever.
- We do.
As I'm getting more educated
about this industry I realized
oh wow this is how they
used to do it back in the day.
I think that's right and in
our world when you're making 26
different segmentations and 26
different creative stories we
have to sit together.
My teams where we and it's funny
in a world of OMD and Group M
and StarCom, we've chipped away
and have won Quaker just gave us
the social media buying duties
even though OMD is the global
agency because we're just able,
in any bake-off of something
that shows a quantifiable sale
including bullshit metrics like
impressions and click-through
like marketing jargon we win
every time because the
creative is the variable.
Right?
And so you guys are at the mercy
of some big buying, it's crazy
to do it that way.
It happened because in 1991
Martin Sorrell realized he could
make more margin by
separating this shit.
This is what pisses me off.
I knew nothing, it takes me 20
fucking minutes as a commonsense
businessman to figure out why this
shit happens and then everybody
goes award-winning
work sells product.
That's my favorite by the way.
I'm sure that
gets said here too.
And definitely gets said
in Cannes 5,000 times.
Award-winning
work sells product.
You mean the studies that were
commissioned by Nielsen's and by
creative shops 25 years
ago to justify creative?
Why is everybody so confused?
Yes, we absolutely do
the buying when we can.
Some places we can't do it
because were boxed out by the
AOR media buying company.
But what's great is we'd rather
lose the business and continue
to push against it to prove it
to them eventually willing our
way to an A/B test which I don't
know miraculously we're like 20
for 20 because when two human
beings are sitting next to each
other and one is saying
okay this is going to go 23 to
27-year-old females who are fans
of Burberry and who've commonly
gone to Bergdorf Goodman, the
creative has a little bit of an
advantage over the people
that are going 18 to 60-year-old
females, go.
So yes we think that
that's going to happen.
I think that will happen to
you guys over the next 10 years
'cause there'll be no options.
You'll be forced to, I don't
know if you guys are owned by
holding company or not,
you're an independent.
You'll build out that principle
or merge with somebody.
It's just going to be important.
People are going
to follow dollars.
Dollars are going
to shift over time.
And again I actually think
there's a huge pot of money in
just programmatic banner.
The funny thing is ironically
especially given the energy
I came in with I'm not trying to
convince most of my clients to
stop doing television.
I think that's a golden
goose that most people are
too romantic about.
I'll let that play itself out.
I'm actually chipping away at
banner programmatic because that
shit they don't
like and it so crazy.
When's the last time, when's
the last time somebody clicked
a banner ad?
There's amazing case studies of
people not even seeing banner
ads like being blind to it now
left sides of websites a lot of
UX UIs designers I don't
know there's any in here are
designing the most least, least,
least important thing on the
left side of website because
they know that we've become
literally blind to that spot
on the right side or left side
depending on the market because
that's where the ads were.
Literally the Facebook
generation the 33-year-olds kind
of right now, 27 to 33 literally
can't see the right side of a
website because that's where the
Facebook ads were for the five
years they were there everyday.
They literally cannot recall.
Cannot recall.
Yes sir. What is your name?
- [Rob] Rob.
- Rob.
- [Rob] What's your tip
for the next biggest thing?
You talked about
Snapchat, what's next?
- You know what's funny?
I always so viscerally push
against this the way to my
brand's positioned in the little
circles that know who I am.
I don't predict.
I don't know.
- [Rob] What'd you invest in?
(laughter)
- So there's four
companies, here's my process.
I've been watching
Snapchat for 3 1/2 years.
I got vocal about a 2 1/2 years
ago this last holiday season
December, January
I got very loud because
I felt it went normal.
Meaning I now do feel based on
the metrics I see that we have
tipped over and 30 and 40 and
50-year-olds will be on Snapchat
in the next 12 to 24 months.
The four platforms that I'm
paying attention to are
all very different.
I'm looking at Peach
because Dom Hoffmann
is a very good product guy.
But Peach is
fucking 41 days old.
It can't even begin to be
meaningful for a year and
I actually am not very
crazy about excited about it.
Anchor. Anchor is
like a voice Twitter.
I don't know if you seen Anchor.
Super interesting to me.
I've always wanted it
because a lot of thoughts.
I've always thought
voice Twitter was real.
So this is the closest thing
I've seen to voice Twitter,
it's called Anchor.
I'm watching that.
Musically is the first platform
that I've seen that has the true
potential to be
the next Snapchat.
If you don't know what Musically
is you should definitely
download it.
It's very interesting.
Based in China.
But exploded in the US and
the UK and other markets.
If you go into your...
Who's Apple here versus Android?
Apple?
Just do me one favor, you'll be
so much smarter for doing it.
Every morning open up
the free app top 150 apps
and look at the charts.
It is pure data of where
people's attention is.
You'll go there and you'll see
Musically is ahead of Twitter
for the last 30 days and
then you'll say, "What's that?"
and then you'll download it.
And then you'll consume it
and then you'll have ideas.
It's a good idea, so
Musically is super interesting.
Musically, Anchor, Peach, After
School's interesting to me.
It's starting to
explode in the US.
You can only get in to
it with a high school ID.
Reminds me a lot of Facebook
where you can
only get in with...
So that's gotten some traction
so I'm paying attention.
So I watch things.
The thing that I do well though
and where I've been able to make
reputation is back to not being
a disruptor, I'm practical.
I'm able to invest in things
when they've already won yet the
market hasn't accepted them.
So when Vine popped what I did
was I just didn't go to sleep
until 3 o'clock in the morning
for a month because I'm busy but
every night from midnight to
3 o'clock in the morning I
literally looked at everything
I listen with my eyes.
I just looked at everything
that people were doing.
And I created an account
and I started playing.
I think the key to a lot of this
is so you know how many of you
have an opinion on Snapchat
and Snapchat advertising
and don't use it?
That to me is a problem.
You know how many meetings I've
been in with creative shops and
digital shops and they say
something about Facebook
that isn't true.
That isn't true.
So my big advantages is that
some actual practitioner versus
a headline reader.
As somebody who's
really deeply in it.
Every day on Digiday and AdAge
and PR Week and Adweek every
day there are multiple headlines
and articles that are inaccurate
or that there's quotes
from people that have vested
financial interest for
that thing not to happen.
So I'm an investor in
Meerkat and wrote a huge check.
I think it's dead.
My vested interest in predicated
on being right so that you guys
invite me back to
sit here again.
So I think that people are very
shortsighted and it's fine when
the market doesn't change for
20 or 30 years you can be a
political animal
and ride your career.
The problem is this
market isn't that.
Nothing that is
important existed 11 years ago.
Not the smart phone, not
Youtube, not Facebook, not
Twitter, not Instagram,
not Snapchat, nothing.
And nobody here
retires in 12 years.
The fuck you think
is going to happen?
(laughter)
This is my point to a lot of
the youngsters that come in.
Let me tell you what I'm
referring to because I'm not
being very frank with you.
I sit on panels in all these
fancy fucking places now ANA,
IRR, fucking Cannes, right?
And I listen to people and I get
to know them because were in the
green room for coffee for
an hour before the panel.
And then eventually you're out
at the fucking Facebook party
and you see that person and you
get a drink and it's blown me
away how many of these people
when you get a couple cocktails
in to them say to me things
like, "Gary, you're right."
(laughter)
And I'm like cool.
Here's the part that bothers me
the most, you're so young you
just stood in front of the
entire industry all that video
is being recorded and in seven
years when you're trying to get
a job at some other place
that now is built on this thing,
they're going to be like
this guy is a fucking idiot.
Why are you doing that?
How many of you saw
"The Big Short" the movie?
Raise your hands
I'm just curious.
I swear to God when I watched
that movie I was like,
"Holy shit, this is the
advertising industry."
Everybody knows it.
And everybody's in on it.
And I'm not mad.
I'm really not.
Even though comes it
comes with a lot of angst.
People are doing what's
right for themselves, I get it.
I'm disappointed because
I wish I could tell everybody
how this plays out.
Because when market change, the
rules change and then what you
thought we were doing the safe
thing for yourself, you were
actually doing the
dangerous thing.
Any other questions?
Yeah.
- [Man] Mark Zuckerberg
plugging Samson.
He's kind of doubling down on
the whole VR thing as being a
thing for the
future of Facebook.
How do you feel about that?
- VR is 100%, not
99, the next platform.
The problem is it's much
further away than a lot of the
tech nerds think.
What I learned with the
internet, VR is internet 1991.
So I'm investing
heavy in VR only B to B.
Of the companies I think will
get bought by Google, Apple,
Samsung and Facebook.
Consumer VR is not even close.
We couldn't even get ourselves
to where Google Glasses,
we're gonna go to VR?
I think VR hits critical mass
when it goes to contact lenses
and it's a good 10, 12, 15
years from now but we'll start.
Gaming, movies everybody in here
in five years will probably put
on a VR set and watch a movie.
Everybody in here in 5 to 7
years will play video game in VR
but the thought that VR is as
close as people think it is it's
not on the consumer level.
Because people are grossly,
grossly underestimating what
makes the fashion industry
tick and how consumer behavior
actually works.
It takes time.
It takes time from anthropology
standpoint we're further away
than we think but
it will happen.
Because here's why I
think it is going to happen.
I, very young in my age,
realized holy shit I am a focus
group of one like everybody
else but I'm such a consummate
salesman and was built that
with such a young age there's
something that I am that
I don't really give a fuck
about my own opinions.
I just try to map what is in
this weird spot in my stomach.
It blew me away when I did the
VR for the first time, not too
long ago, the real VR that's
coming kinda some
of the preview shit.
I took the headset off after an
hour now mind you I want to give
you a little context, nobody
loves people more than me.
You can be tied with me but
I love human interaction.
So funny social media when
that was being debated,
that's a gateway drug to
actual communication.
I love this.
Love it.
I took the headset off and
literally subconsciously which
was the part that kind of took
me aback, I took it off and said
why would anybody ever take this
off and it fucked with me,
It still kinda fucks with me.
Because I like was like fuck if
that was my purest reaction to
myself the whole thought of
what's real life and what's not
feels very real because if you
really think about it, if you
really look at a 15, 17,
19-year-old is the life that are
living in our phone more
or less real the life of the
living out here?
There's some crazy
ass shit coming.
I think he's betting
because he bets long-term.
He can afford to.
But I'm not expecting all of us
sitting at home being actually
here right now anytime soon.
But we'll all see it.
I think we we'll all see it.
Yeah man.
- [Man 3] (inaudible)
- I don't. No, I don't.
I'll tell you why,
I don't judge humans.
We have a good track record.
I think human beings are the
most underrated
brand in the world.
I think that if we took your
great, great, great, grandfather
pulled him up revived him, made
him fresh and sat him here and
let him watch everything we
do, he'd be really fucking sad.
I think that if you take
generations, I mean there was a
time only 40 years ago that
people felt that Elvis shaking
his hips was the devil.
I think it's evolution.
I actually, I'm very actually
very happy about technology.
let me explain.
The cliché current version of
sad in the following you go out
with your partner and you go
to a restaurant and you see a
couple sitting there having
dinner and both of them are on
the phone the whole time.
And you judge, because we
love to judge, don't we?
You look at somebody
and you go that's sad.
Look at those two.
They fucking on the
phone and whole time.
That's sad.
I see the following looking
around for most of you are old
enough to remember going to
the restaurant 10 years ago and
seeing a couple that sat across
from each other and didn't say a
fucking word to each
other the entire dinner.
So what I see is that same
couple 10 years later and
I'm happy for them
because unlike--
(laughter)
I am. I'm being dead serious.
Unlike 10 years ago where they
had to like this and fucking be
miserable now they have
options to be happy at least.
I really don't,
I don't think it is sad.
I think people take the half
glass empty point of view on a
lot of these issues.
If you look at data of average
14-year-old girl in America she
now claims to have many more
friends than she did just 10
years ago because if you're
introverted or kind of little
bit different 14-year-old girl
in America 12, 15 years ago and
probably all over the world
and the serendipity of the high
school that you're in didn't
give you the fucking luck of
having another friend or two
that had those interests, you
are isolated but now you
have unlimited options.
Through your phone or
through Twitch and video games.
There's a lot of healthy
things that are happening.
Maybe I'm an optimist but the
reason I'm not scared or sad is
'cause we proven for a
very long time to adapt.
Evolution is real.
We're going to become robots.
People can think it
is sad, I get it.
You know, it's different.
A lot of people think that
interracial marriages are sad.
way girls are dress are sad.
There's a lot of things that
are sad. Men aren't men anymore.
The great
generation we're tough.
We're metrosexual.
I think a lot of
things are judged.
I don't judge the way
that we communicate.
We've evolved go read what we
wrote about the telephone and
the television and video games
and cell phones, evolution baby.
Yes.
- [Man 4] I know you don't
predict but do you think that in
our future that people, you
know, that classic form of being
together with
somebody (inaudible).
- I'd be lying--
- [Man 4] It's tiring, isn't it?
(laughter)
- There's a lot if you want to
go really up there's is a couple
things I think are really
interesting that are going to
change our relationships.
Number one, I think
that it's hard to hide.
There's a female researcher at
MIT that really blew my mind
about the notion of
marriage being built on the
shadows of society.
Her thesis I can't remember
her name I want to give it
to you guys.
Her thesis was the marriage was
able to be executed was there
was a lot of secrecy.
And if you look at her theory
on 1920s, '30s, '40s, '50s
housewife just looking the other
way and then evolution as women
became more equals of just
cheating but not being
exposed, hiding.
And as we go into a world
where it's just hard to hide.
Completely and everything's
being documented as privacy goes
less and less away
what happens to that.
I think back to VR there's
some incredible thinking around
what's going to happen would
with VR porn that I think is,
it's just true.
They're the fastest
innovators in the space.
VR makes your brain
think you're 99% there.
What happens for men with
porn that think is 99% real
in a VR environment?
I think back to your thing
for us to think that shit's not
gonna change and not gonna
change aggressively with very
different technologies,
yeah I think a lot of
things are gonna change.
But I would also tell you and
again, may be predicated on the
optimism, I think the more
that the more that we expose the
shadows that we may not see it
'cause it takes a long time but
if you think about, I'll
actually give you a
focus group of one.
As I started getting internet
fame and realizing more my shit
was going to be out there
I took selfies on the way here,
people in street.
I've lived a different way.
It's interesting how freeing it
can be if you kind of, no joke
as a real funny where I'm trying
to get to I literally live my
life at this point as if
it's on the record 24/7.
I'm conditioning myself for
knowing that all of you are
going to wear contact lenses
in 10 years and you could be
streaming that or recording it.
This is real.
You can wish how it's not gonna
be but these things are coming
and so I don't know exactly how
to answer your question of like
what's going to happen but I
definitely think there's
gonna be friction.
I think the way things are now
are being challenged not just in
television ads versus Facebook
stream versus Snapchat but in
like all social norms
and you know
it's just a different world, man.
One more. My man.
How are you?
Yep.
- [Man 5] I'm obviously‚..
(inaudible) A lot of that is
going to change.
You talk a lot about EQ.
(inaudible) hustle.
Gist about that.
- Thank you for knowing that.
Yeah, one thing
I didn't touch on that
I appreciate you alluding to.
I think this is been a very
big reason we were able to grow
VaynerMedia and I think as you
get bigger it gets harder and
just in general.
For people that know a
little bit about me.
Being an immigrant I don't think
I have all that many talents.
But what I definitely know more
than anything is that hard work
is an absolute variable.
I think way too many people,
this whole notion of well Gary I
work smart and that somehow
substitutes working hard is
really quite silly.
I think it breeds itself in
talented organizations like
this, and startups where one
thinks their talent can trump
somebody outworking them.
For example,
creative is subjective.
Delivering
something on time is not.
And so these are things that we
kind of think a whole lot about.
I think no question in a
world where a lot of stuff being
commoditized because of the
scale of the infrastructure of
society that hard work is a
stunning variable but it's only
hustle to what you actually
want to happen in your life.
So the cliché way I talk about
it is I work 15 and 17 hours a
day because I have
these business ambitions.
But I would argue I had a very
telling meeting the other day
where I have a friend who is
made over $100 million and he's
sitting there and he's crying
and complaining to me that he
doesn't spend the time with his
family and I was like literally
I had no love for him and he's
a real good friend and
I'm like, "Fuck you."
You have nothing but money.
You're not doing it for that.
You're being selfish you want
to spend time with your family,
spend more time
with your family.
Hustle can come
in a lot of forms.
It depends on what
you want to deploy it.
But if you want to be great at
your craft if you want to be
great at what you do
professionally to even begin to
think in today's environment
that you can pull that off an
eight hour day is laughable.
It is just not real.
And so I'm a very, very,
very big believer in hard work
because I think it is
the differentiation in the
marketplace.
If talent was enough all the
number one draft picks and all
these sports leagues they would
win and all these different
artists that have
music talent would win.
Hustle I think is the backbone
of how we built what we built.
It was funny as we started
hiring older people, you know,
I'm busy.
So I'd have meetings at 8 or 9
PM at the office that's when I
can meet them and I knew I was
onto something as I was starting
to hire more senior people
because every one of them were
on the floor stunned how
many fucking people were at the
VaynerMedia at
8:30 at night working.
And they would always
comment on like,
"Holy shit. Huh?"
And the truth is and this is not
a joke I do feel like our hustle
at 650 and 100 million and a
little bit of love finally is
coming down a little bit.
Success absolutely
pushes against hustle.
One of the reasons I'm doing my
daily vlog and documenting it is
to remind all these fuckers
that hard work is a factor.
So. Thank you
guys for having me.
(applause)
Thank you.